well after Fantasia gave a disappointing
turnout at the box office it seemed
Disney had to go back to the traditional
narrative Dumbo was the fourth film they
ever released it's a curious choice
because well it is artistically
interesting at times it's not anything
really groundbreaking Snow White
Pinocchio and Fantasia you could
definitely argue broke some new ground
Dumbo is just or your typical kids flick
but it's not bad actually something I
always noticed about Dumbo is that Dumbo
is never actually the focus he doesn't
even talk he just sort of walks around
looking cute I mean it works he's big
eyed curious and all those are things
you expect out Disney characters but the
focus of the movie is the rest of the
world the world of the circus the world
of the animals the world of getting
drunk it's all about strange visuals
he's very much the observer not the
focus but hey that's fine by me I love
weird imagery especially if it's brought
to us by Disney this story is very basic
an elephant gives birth to a little
elephant that's born with big ears he's
considered an outcast and often gets
into trouble for it
while one kid goes too far and making
fun of him the mother takes the guy and
starts beating a crab up plus she gets
thrown away in the cellar and Dumbo is
left on his own just with one little
friend a circus mouse the rest of the
movie is just things going wrong weird
people and weird things approaching him
and I'm Dumbo looking confused again I
don't have a problem with it it's done
well it's done reasonably well it's just
a weird strange environment that they
build for it's like because most posters
showed Dumbo flying but really he
doesn't fly until the last 10 minutes it
just proves to be your basic Rudolph the
Red Nosed Reindeer story it works well
enough like I said the weird angles and
often bizarre tone really helped to give
the film a very interesting identity and
entry sort of sets it apart from the
other Disney films now there is big
debate about whether or not the crows in
this movie are racist obviously they're
all played by black actors and they do
use slang and say the word brother every
once in a while
but Disney never pulled it like they did
song of the south or some of the other
racially insensitive cartoons and from
the standpoint of just a dumb white kid
I thought they were cool they hit style
they had class they're the ones that
made Dumbo fly what's not to light their
friggin awesome
now again I'm speaking as a dumb white
kid maybe there's something there I'm
missing but for me personally I never
saw the problem the pink elephant scene
though entirely pointless is friggin
awesome I love this scene as a kid I
love it now it's weird it's strange its
kind of dark it's almost creepy but it's
also very enjoyable the animation is
flowing the weird designs they come up
with are just surreal it's just pure
craziness and yeah there's really no
point to it but I forget love it they do
have some emotional scenes to the scene
where Dumbo X's mother is one of those
big tearjerkers that every girl I know
always goes and nuts whenever they see
and like I said before the world they
create for Dumbo is always big massive
and threatened so when you get to the
happy Pappy points though it's all the
more enjoyable overall there was a
decent movie it's not up to par with
some of the more traditional Disney
films but I don't think it was meant to
be he sort of set its own rules and it's
stuck with it I think it's pretty
awesome for that it's a fun film with
some fun sequences
you